une femme enceinte évacué en urgence sur
une civière
le bombardement vient de frapper en
plein coeur l'hôpital pour enfants de
mario paul
il y a des blessés c'est le chaos
toi tu est intacte tout va bien j'ai
peur pour ma maman
la panique et la peur se lisent sur les
visages
à quelques mètres de là un homme un
ukrainien filmé avec son téléphone
portable
à un tir d'artillerie lourde
c'est la maternité
des femmes que l'on aide à marcher sorte
en titubant des bâtiments
à travers les couloirs des tables à
langer
délits ont été projetés
sous l'effet de l'explosion tout a été
soufflé
ce qu'il ya des gens ici
de l'extérieur les dégâts sont tout
aussi impressionnants d'après les
témoins la bombe serait à l'origine de
cet immense cratère presque cinq fois la
taille dana
selon un bilan provisoire au moins 17
adultes ont été blessés parce que le
président hélène ce qui décrit comme une
frappe aérienne russe
c'est une atrocité combien de temps
encore le monde sera complice de la
terreur
depuis quelques jours les troupes russes
en cercle et pilonnent marioupol
l'hôpital pédiatrique est loin d'être le
seul touché
de nombreux autres bâtiments ont été
détruits
transformant la ville portuaire en un
champ de ruines
et victimes de frappes d'artillerie
incessants entre chaque heure chaque
minute chaque seconde
selon le ministère de la défense russe
le bombardement de l'hôpital de
marioupol est une provocation
ukrainienne d'après le ms 19
installations de santé ont été détruites
depuis le début de la guerre